puede hacerle una pregunta íntima al
grupo te definirías como activa pasiva
versátil
[Música]
6 versus 1 sitio con 6 chicas basándose
en sus atuendos le pedimos a ariana que
tuviera una cita con sus chicas
basándose en su atuendo y personalidad
hola me llamo ariana tengo 27 años y soy
una reclutadora corporativa en fintech
company soy muy femenina por eso me he
visto así la moda es algo muy importante
para mí por lo que también es necesario
que mi compañera tenga eso inculcado soy
muy selectiva por eso es mi culpa soy la
razón del por qué estoy soltera sin duda
al final la personalidad será número uno
para mí pero un buen atuendo será la
clave
primeras rondas zapatos
[Música]
y estoy lista
o vaya bien tenemos una gran variedad de
estilos aquí
las flores son muy arriesgadas son
doctor martín sí me encantan gracias
bien amo la comida de hecho me atrevería
a decir que es como mi lenguaje de amor
que cocinar y es para mí
[Música]
yo cocino recetas de 'tik tok' si es en
la noche fría prepararía un rico ramen
solo recuerda quería lo mejor que puedo
si bien no son estupendo te pusiste muy
nerviosa por eso me gusta ser muy
aventurera con la comida si hay un plato
que no conozco pienso que es divertido
tratar de prepararlo o algo podríamos
probarlo juntas yo preparar y ajax yuca
no sé si ya lo has probado antes se hace
con pimientos rojos y tomates es un poco
picante y lleva huevos escalfados sería
cocinar comida persa conozco algunas
recetas de mi familia y haría tacos todo
tipo de comida mexicana es fácil y muy
deliciosa de hecho estoy perfeccionando
mi receta hacer la masa para pizza
podemos preparar juntas pizzas muy ricas
yo hago una salsa casera para espaguetis
soy vegetariana es una pequeña
restricción pero puedo preparar
diferentes platos me encanta cocinar
hago comida al curry un sofrito lo que
sea genial sí
me da mucha pena la última concursante
es la única vegetariana voy a tener que
eliminar te lo siento mucho jajaja qué
lástima
[Música]
los seres hermosa esta es otra razón por
la que estoy soltera te explico pues soy
mexicana bien y mi familia tiene un
rancho en méxico siento que te
traumatizaría si te llevo una finca y
ves un cordero de cabeza con la sangre
chorreando ya veo si lo entiendo gusto
de conocerte
me siento como una idiota
[Música]
o genial esto es wow es muy interesante
bien puedo saber número 2
cómo describirías tu estilo
creo que soy femenina pero tengo días en
que uso pantalones cortos y una cadena
puedo hacerle una pregunta íntima al
grupo te definirías como activa pasiva
versátil ninguna u otra
bueno si me lo permiten prefiero ser
activa me gusta tener el movimiento para
mí honestamente creo que depende de la
persona y cómo es nuestra energía pienso
que dependiendo de la persona me siento
de manera diferente
yo diría que versátil a mí me gustaría
decir versátil pero creo que para mí
también depende de con quién esté y la
energía que tengamos mitín desde se
activa pero creo que me inclino más
versátil tienen algún problema si una
mujer es principalmente activa yo soy
siempre la líder
mi mamá va a ver esto
hola mamá
si todos si dos a bien a eliminar a la
concursante número uno lo siento mucho
ahora queremos la bolita grados muy
bonita tan gracias cuando les pregunté a
todas qué rol elegían tú dijiste
que pensé oh amiga no tengas pena de los
metales versátil hubiese sido una mejor
respuesta pero si quiero que me digan
papi dijo que fue
[Risas]
estoy sudando pero también gracias no
hay de qué
amo el pelo rizado es una de mis
debilidades estoy un poco decepcionada
de mí misma hora
ahora eliminaré a la concursante número
horas
hola mucho mucho gusto me gusta tu
maquillaje gracias a mí tus zapatos
gracias soy mala maquillando no puedo
hacerlo si fuiste muy alegre y graciosa
creo que nuestros estilos no encajarían
muy bien de acuerdo lo entiendo
esto es muy divertido me gustaría
escuchar la historia de cómo salieron
del armario en la secundaria mi mejor
amiga salía con un chico pero nosotras
accidentalmente nos enamoramos
en ese momento también se lo contaste a
tu familia empecé a salir con ella a
finales de mi último año en la
secundaria y fue cuando se los conté te
importa si pregunto si ellos lo
aceptaron o no para nada y si mis padres
de verdad lo aceptaron mi familia me
apoya completamente están claros nos
llevamos muy bien fui a una escuela
católica y me gustaba darle motivos a la
gente para
apoyarme
por eso me declaré bisexual y luego fui
a la universidad y me declaré lesbiana
así que definitivamente me identifico
contigo me declaro bisexual la mayor
parte de mi vida adulta luego me declaré
hace un año como lesbiana mi mama
encontró mi historial de búsqueda en
google las dos lloramos y luego comimos
un pastel
maravilloso buenas historias tengo la
curiosidad de saber por qué yo estoy a
ciegas al igual que obviamente todos
ustedes pueden decirme cuál es su tipo
es variado normalmente me gustan más las
chicas femeninas con una vibra orgullosa
de ser gay me explico me gusta la vibra
gay hay algo que sientas que eso me da
una energía gay no es como un accesorio
de vestir es más como el contacto visual
siento que mi tipo no tiene mucho que
ver con la apariencia femenina sino con
la personalidad que tiene y tiende a
llevarme mejor con las personas que les
gusta tomar el mando o que les gusta ser
el líder y también me gusta que sea un
poco esotérica y reservada si yo también
me inclino más hacia la personalidad si
se trata de clasificar a todas mis ex
parejas todas serían diferentes pero
definitivamente me inclino hacia las
personas seguras de sí mismas divertidas
que amen reírse como soy kravis su mente
así
[Risas]
[Música]
entonces
voy a eliminar
la número 3 primero
[Risas]
hola mujeres hermosas como estaría
encantado bien igual
me gusta todo está pero creo que el
cinturón resaltó me lo iba a poner que
lo sabía él como campestre claro dónde
sí
lo lamento
eliminar a la número uno
veamos
ah
eres hermosa y con mucho gusto así es
igualmente lo siento mucho no te
arrepientas sé cómo te sientes es más
difícil estar en tu posición
estás lista para ver tu elección final
si estoy lista
[Risas]
me encanta
me gustaron tus respuestas y mencionaste
que te gusta el picante y el espíritu
latino por eso pensé querido país de
méxico y cuando mencionaste lo de crecer
en una granja me recordó cuando visitaba
a mi familia varias veces y literalmente
las cabras colgaban la piel de las
cabras les gustaría salir juntas en una
cita
creo que tal vez no lo sé creo que soy
muy joven te ves muy joven sí
no no no quiero decir que no porque
suena así te veo en una aplicación de
citas pensaría es demasiado joven si ni
siquiera ajustaría mi configuración
mayor de 25 pues si cree que soy mayor
de 25 no dijiste que tenías 20
sigo siendo la razón del por qué estoy
soltera porque soy muy selectivo justo
su atuendo gran chica empoderada muchas
estaban nerviosas pero yo estaba
emocionada porque en verdad quería
conocer quién sería la chica además me
gusta rodearme de personas que dice así
que fue divertido para mí no importa si
una mujer es extrovertida o introvertida
sé si te sientes cómoda y segura cómo te
vistes tu atuendo tendrá 20 puntos lo
que pienso cuando me arreglo en la
mañana es solo este es mi avatar este es
mi muñeca yo la visto y lo hago como
quiera no para los demás supongo que lo
único que me gustaría que las personas
sepan es que sé quién soy y me siento
cómoda con quién soy suscríbete a
jubilee para más vídeos versus uno
quieres estar en un vídeo regístrate en
jubilee media puntocom
[Música]